so you're being strangely cryptic as you
wrap your magic hair around my injured
hand Disney movies undergo a lot of
changes before they hit the big screen
and sometimes characters are totally
unrecognizable from their original
concept art check out what these 10
Disney characters were actually supposed
to look like Flynn Rider
Rapunzel's love interest might look like
the perfect Prince and Disney had a
bunch of women meet to decide what the
perfect man would look like their
feedback led to the creation of the
Eugene we know and love but what was he
supposed to look like before the survey
was taken let's just say it was nothing
like the focus group described he was
tall with huge shoulders and a small
head and he was blond
we just can't imagine this original
Flynn giving us the smolder we're glad
they changed his look Beast
if a character is just called the Beast
there is a lot of room for
interpretation the Beast we grew up with
is kind of adorable he's got a bear cow
dog looks going on but he didn't always
look this way the earliest concept art
had him looking way less mythical can
you imagine what Beauty and the Beast
would look like if he was a monkey well
that's exactly what he was the beasts
original face looked just like a
mandrill it's just a choice for a
monster mandrels can be really mean
Princess Anna Anna from frozen is one of
the most popular princesses ever she is
a sweet face and fiery red hair her
personality matches her appearance
perfectly but it didn't always the early
sketches of Princess Anna made the sweet
little sister look kind of mean
disappear look on her face just doesn't
match the Anna we know today at all one
thing that didn't change too much is her
clothing all of her clothing was
inspired by traditional Norwegian
fashion we think they did a great job at
evolving this character King Triton
Disney had a unique challenge with the
Little Mermaid they had to make mermaids
and mermen looked
totally relatable to their audience we
all know King Triton as the white-haired
caring father of Ariel but he was going
to look a lot different
the earliest sketches of him are
shocking he's completely bald he has
this crazy long mustache and are those
pointed ears something about him looks
way less kingly than the Triton we've
grown accustomed to we can't believe how
different these two sea kings look Carl
Fredricksen
everyone knows Carl from up the
animators successfully made him look
like a grumpy old man and a sweet guy
who loved his wife
that's a hard look to achieve he's got
the perfect grandpa vibe going on but
the first sketches were wild Carl was
going to be way less human-like and take
on a frog like appearance he was even
drawn as green and look at that huge
toad like mouth up could have been a
totally different movie think that's
crazy stay tuned to find out how
terrifying Ursula
used to be Princess Aurora the classic
Disney Princess have been icons for
several generations and the star of
Sleeping Beauty is no exception we can't
imagine Princess Aurora as anything but
the blond beauty that she is
but her animators had a completely
different concept for the sleeping
princess she was going to have jet-black
hair her original art also had her
wearing a peplum top and a shorter
flared skirt that doesn't look like
medieval German fashion at all they
fixed her clothes and changed her hair
color in the final version Aladdin the
Prince of Thieves stole our hearts from
the moment he stole a loaf of bread
Aladdin might give Flynn Rider a run for
his money as the most handsome Disney
Prince but he didn't always look like
the guy Jasmine fell in love with the
entire Aladdin movie changed a lot from
its earliest concepts but take a look at
the first Aladdin he looks a lot younger
and more cartoonish than the final
version and wears his iconic purple vest
we wonder how many times Aladdin was
reimagined before they decided on the
version we know Rapunzel this story of
Rapunzel is a really old fairy tale but
our Rapunzel is one of the modern Disney
Princesses the princess from tangled has
the
guys and round-faced that is typical of
modern Disney CGI but her concept art is
unrecognizable the early Rapunzel is
gorgeous but she looks a lot older and
more serious we can't imagine her
dancing around the tower and hanging out
with Pascal can you imagine this
Rapunzel with the original Flynn it
wouldn't even be the same movie such a
crick in the neck genie nobody really
knows what a genie looks like so it was
up to Disney to create something iconic
for Aladdin and we can't imagine a genie
being anything other than a big blue
dude but the concept artist for genie
had something totally different in mind
the original sketch featured
monster-like hands and what is up with
his forehead his grin was pretty creepy
too
one thing that did stay the same from
the original was the pony tail the
original sketch is in black and white so
we don't know if genie was always going
to be blue
Ursula talked about a poor unfortunate
soul Ursula the sea witch from The
Little Mermaid went through a lot of
changes banished a child she was
originally imagined to be thin and regal
but then the animators came up with
something truly terrifying this Ursula
looks like something out of a nightmare
as if the octopus style which wasn't
scary enough in the original they
probably decided that this Ursula would
frighten way too many kids and maybe
some adults too they toned down her look
and made her more purple for the final
version which original Disney character
did you like the most
let us know in the comments thanks for
watching don't forget to like this video
and subscribe to the things we'll catch
you later
[Music]